the arrest of former president juan
orlando hernandez has left many in
honduras stunned he was escorted away in
chains after dozens of honduran security
forces surrounded his home for several
hours
the country's security minister ramon
sabiyon tells al jazeera there were
concerns the former honduran leader may
have been planning to evade arrest
we were able to take the appropriate
measures in response to information that
suggested there could be some risk or
danger of escape so we made the decision
it's better to err on the side of excess
measures than to fail to uphold the law
for years juan orlando hernandez has
faced accusations of links to drug
trafficking and that his rise to power
was fueled by bribes and drug money
officials in the united states also
claimed that corruption inherent within
the hernandez administration
led to a deterioration of democratic
institutions and a social decay that
fueled a historic wave of migration from
the country
though president hernandez spent years
portraying himself as tough on drug
trafficking the same extradition
legislation he helped create is now
being used against him the detention
facility behind the gates of this army
barracks in the honduran capital is
perhaps the last place he expected to
find himself
honduras's security minister says this
arrest should serve as an example to all
public servants that no one in the
country is above the law
this sets an example for the entire
community and above all for the
international community so that the
country is seen with different eyes with
transparency and equality of law
that is the other aspect
not applying the law to only a segment
of the population but to all of those
who hold public office
in the honduran capital news of
hernandez's arrest has been met with
mixed emotions and not everyone is
optimistic that the downfall of the man
who only three weeks ago was president
of the country will bring about an end
to the country's war on drugs
this war is one of those things that
never ends it's always more more
kingpins it's an endless war you capture
one and another takes his place
hopefully things begin to calm down
like deaths
all of that can be reduced god willing
though some view the hernandez
extradition case as a stain on the
office of the presidency many in
honduras have expressed hope that the
country might finally turn a page after
years of being plagued by violence
linked to drug trafficking
manuel rapalo al jazeera